what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
division season two episode seven eight
and nine today joined by MJ Tesla follow
us Star Wars expert on that social media
use the force to leave a like
full-length Direction watch your luxury
sink up with your own coffee I'm sorry
rejects on a patreon page I think you
all have joined just for this show alone
but of course these episodes are
sponsored by one of the greatest
sponsors we've ever worked with I don't
mean that in any hyperbolic sense
whatsoever move out of the way back take
you again to me honest for sponsoring
this video guys I'm in a onesie I've
never owned a onesie and my epidermis
has never felt more comfortable nay I
need a better word than comfortable I
feel
as snug as a bug in a rug I obviously
love their clothing I went to the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere
and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants and people would not stop
talking about it easily the most
comfortable one there at the event now I
am venturing further into the galaxy far
far away you might say with this limited
edition print of grogu AKA baby Yoda is
the child himself grogu has traveled
across the Galaxy and into our hearts
and now you can meditate with him and
galactically soft undies socks bralettes
loungewear and more available in sizes
extra small to 4XL like I said the new
Star Wars Prince is limited so grab this
bounty now before it's all gone they
also gave me their shorts which again is
so soft and perfect fitting too even my
wife loves to wear them speaking of my
wife I even got this bralette for her
too I said take it off I'm showing it in
the video woman she loves seeing me in
this underwear my Jedi Mind Tricks to
keep her attracted to me don't work but
this underwear is doing the job wearing
it right now I've never been more
relaxed on camera sitting has just
generally never felt so soothing but yes
rejection the hype is real you're not
impressed with me on these your first
pair is on the house Seth is a promise
so to get 25 off your first order and
free standard shipping go to mianis.com
rejects once again that is mionys.com
Rejects and May the force be with you
always I hope they partner up with us
again because
yes
[Music]
I like this already trained
oh this looks good Rings feel good what
do they even want charuk
that's the partition trade we are
approaching the Insurgent hideouts very
treacherous
some major Clone Wars Vibes in this
animation Style
not now Ronnie but he gave it to me he
said no no
again they're from the trolley
the best rightful
default until I'm back
I'm like 90 certain that I know that
Jedi
exciting
what are you doing that way I saw it
myself
[Music]
thank you
dumbass Stormtroopers
oh cause she wanted to play a flute
we saw what you did I love the theme of
little girls making stupid ass mistakes
are here
[Music]
nice
eyes
oh what's up
oh awesome
[Music]
that's a great shot
damn
this is cool oh no so fun
[Music]
oh ow right to the face
you're almost there
all the trouble you caused you want to
just complain that's our destination
[Music]
I love how they can Infuse other
cultures into this
he threw a loaf at me don't listen to
him
final warning you maggots
wow
storm is approaching
table number six
these are the literal Dark Times
um that girl just levitated the platter
did we miss something stop using the
force little girl that feels like a
no-brainer right
[Music]
uh please be an Inquisitor of some kind
I feel like that'd be super neat uh
that is awesome she hungry so her
stomach just starts making some sounds
a girl they saw in the train with
unusual balls I don't suppose you know
any such girl with unusual powers that
old man to the right I went to these
Farm Villages just beyond the train
tracks and burnt them all
no survivors
nothing
maybe you're right there you are
it's totally here you're right
foreign
[Music]
maybe that's why the Clone Wars
animation was purposeful
whoa
oh this is great
damn
like entering the speed of force his
lightsabers and his Cane too
cool Inquisitor leave them alone
this is her
ah that was her fantastic you're dying
all right not what I was expecting but
I'm super here for it
oh this is great it's like a PS5
10 out of 10 old lady Jedis or what's up
yeah this was like a cinematic cutscene
that is the proper use of that
lightsaber
damn
[Music]
oh a Jedi
God it doesn't look like a cinematic
cutscene like a game that looks amazing
quickly now
Moses ah they're probably gonna end up
on a hidden path
I always knew you were meant for bigger
things
it's time you take that path now
oh that's sad this part is only meant
for you there are others like you here
no one ever takes enough of an
empathetic approach when they have to
say goodbye to their family sorry you
can't go the bandits right for
feast
oh
mm-hmm
flute
yeah
oh May the force be with you
that's amazing
[Music]
that was amazing I really like that one
a lot man that was a 10 out of 10 for me
I think it's really cool this is coming
out when so much of this season of
vision seems to at the first season felt
so much more like
mainly anime yeah or or like different
types of riffs within that side of the
world this is so much more worldwide
yeah I mean it's a flavor of of
everything kinds of cultures Global
animation world has to offer the forces
with everyone and and I think it's cool
too because I feel like a lot of these
Studios don't always get to do what
they're best at yeah because of like
market demand like this I want to make a
petition make that Cannon yeah like I
want to know more I want to continue to
follow that Adventure I would watch so
much of that I can only like imagine for
for somebody from like India how
meaningful and special something like
this was see like some of my favorite
elements from Indian filmmaking Traverse
into the Star Wars Universe yeah stuff
like this is always really sweet because
you're watching it and like clearly
there's some really really big fans here
obviously you're big fans of the Clone
Wars and took so many wonderful elements
part of me wonders if like some of the
model assets that they used throughout
it might even be from clone wars and
then just reimagined in terms of like
the final art style because it's just
like slight little tweaks that you you
notice from it what a strong strong
episode yeah well I think it's really
cool to be doing this especially because
a lot of parts of the world have
experienced you know Wars as well
um like real life historical Wars and
you know a lot of Star Wars often it's
only America and Germany obviously but
no I think a lot of you know Star Wars
that has been like mainly a riff on you
know like World War II where here you
you see these other parts of the world
that are also uh that can identify with
it in terms of its oppression and trying
to find Hope and having their
underground systems where they were able
to build a rebellion or you know find
these kinds of individuals I thought was
excellent you know like I think there
was like a lot of like fun Peril that
this episode had with some gorgeous
animation but that right at the end was
breathtakingly like PS5 high quality
Graphics to me in that way I'm like yeah
this is like the kind of cutscenes you
look up and you keep watching yeah and
it was just such a surprise like you
would never suspect the old lady yes
it tricked it tricked and I bet that was
purposeful of course of course they
wanted to throw off the well it's funny
because the character that I thought I
literally said right before like oh yeah
his lightsaber is in a cane and they had
his species in the background which I
thought was like such a might have been
intentional to throw it off yeah to make
it about a brother and sister and a
brother trying to like kind of that last
of us kind of style of like I gotta take
my brother and sister but is my little
girl at the same time yeah I'm taking
them across because there's someone
special and important and they have to
let them go classic man DeLorean even
does it you know yeah this is like very
classic Star Wars but with Indian
influence right yeah I I thought even
like the use of the train uh was a great
like like solo like
well at like in Indian culture like the
use of trains Community like it's it's a
there's a lot of layers uh and I just I
don't know there's so many beautiful
cultural touches yeah while we're
exploring the Galaxy I feel like it's a
friendly reminder that like our world is
in so many ways just as big and just as
exciting alrighty guys that was an
amazing one another great one knocked
out you ready to watch next one no well
let's do it anyway you have no choice
super sexy rejects we are here to watch
the next episode of Star Wars Visions
we're gonna watch episode 8 right now
just two more to go is this the one
where Luke drinks the milk yeah not the
blue one the straight out of the
Ralph's grocery store did you ever
figure out what material the meanders is
made from the skin of God the skin of
God
please be tattooing please
oh this is striking
I love space capes
I love holes
[Music]
I think they're digging for
what are they digging for oh he's a
fighter
[Music]
holocron lightsaber wreckage of a ship
kind of crystals I think so
guess so I wonder if they're on Jetta
should probably reward them
wow
slave mining
I love this time lapse
it's like an app
build your own kyber Crystal slave camp
the bottom well done Commander
Kill Them All
all right
drool
ah wow I was born in the darkness this
is where pain comes from are they just
trapped there I hope we Flash oh boy you
gotta become like Ant-Man and
quantumania and just climb on top of
each other
well this is cruel as hell yeah I
appreciate how unique this is I've
plotted the best course to climb
when I get to the top I'll go there to
find help help I my voice stay here it's
just too dangerous you're a Negative
Nancy Grandpa he'll do the right thing
if they follow their light I don't see
any other way out have you seen Hamilton
yeah that's the voice of Lafayette you
think so feels like it David Diggs David
Diggs good job everyone has an inner
light no matter how dark it's always
there to guide you the right way
don't be afraid to use your voice and
remind them to follow the light
I hope you're right Michael or else I'm
gonna be coming at you saying not all
black people sound the same
you don't know if the voice actor is
black Greg
oh you got me
he's climbing out awesome defeat Diggs
is Jewish so I feel like I get a pass
what I'd give to have arms like that
oh the humanity
oh he's gonna make little hand tools
oh hell yeah hell yeah a little bug
armadillo where are you
he's gonna tell them I'll go screw
themselves you might become a cage
fighter
ah wait is this the city where Jack
Black and lizard Queen
look at this richly diverse Community
excuse me
this is really sad it's like living in
New York City oh true or L.A
flight you found the light follow it
follow the light cray there is a giant
pit hundreds of us are trapped down
there deep below the surface even
children children
we helped build this city and now we
need your help if you follow me I can
show you oh my God I hope this has a
bleak ass ending I would love for her to
be oblique you there hold it
One Jump Ahead of the
[Music]
yep
poor guy just climbed a mountain
but I can throw him back in the pit
let's get Blake
that is a haunting illustration I don't
think is gonna wow
[Music]
oh he's straight up dead
wow it's such hopelessness
[Music]
They're Gonna Shine a Light they need to
know we're here
Crystal
follow the light
that's cool
[Music]
oh that's really sad
oh
no no no no no no they're coming back
I kind of would like it if they didn't I
know just go in really dark
see rich people are good
rich people are good rich people are
good just follow the line
really nice that Elon Musk lended all
those ships for them blue check mark
it's only seven dollars
[Music]
hell yeah
nice
you're a wizard Harry
I don't get it wow that was
heartbreaking that was a heartbreaking
one despite all the jokes you
specifically kept making no that was
really heartbreaking
would have been nicer and in a really
dark place
no I'm glad what the hell are rich
people gonna do huh yeah they would
actually they didn't even walk out there
they're gonna offer you refuge in the
city that you built everybody like bring
a camera
let's yeah let's monetize this if I can
uh get get some publicity on this this
will help me out yeah hey guys I just
found these people down in a hole and
we're gonna we're gonna help them out
today
uh like And subscribe comment below Mr
Beast here to tell you you get eight
thousand dollars if you get one of these
people out of the hole that's my
philanthropy work uh last cat of the
hole he gets nothing oh well so sad too
bad boom eight minutes clocking in
videos
that was really sad just um
I mean the divide and
this one spoke to classism
no no no no classism
that's a big word woke
uh sorry
Society
no I I agree what happens when you film
Eight Episodes back to back when your
conversations take you I for one didn't
see any
socioeconomic underlying message that
they were trying to convey in this piece
what I saw is a bunch of people dig a
hole Craig and I don't really understand
why and then they bitched afterwards
yeah you have a new home they built you
a new town Yeah by far you forgot to
bring rations with you to survive you
literally have shovels yeah you could
start again you could eat the dead
people it's true it's an endless so long
as you keep having children yeah there's
an endless endless supply oh it's we're
not going there that's a dark dark place
but I do appreciate tonally that this
wasn't afraid to go a little bit darker
but it sounds like you and I want even
more the most realistic representation
from the what Society is really like in
the situation I feel like the best
realistic representation of what
societies like in real life in Star Wars
is Anakin mowing down younglings yeah
um true true Amen to that brother watch
that I watch the whole expanded version
of them did you watch they don't they
don't have one where you watch the
children did you watch a fan film of I
would make that fan film I'm 90 minutes
long use like that's enough to get away
with being a feature do you want to
figure out if it was
yeah please I hope it's totally not
uh you nailed it you nailed it oh Steve
Blum was the commander oh that's so for
those that don't know he plays Greg's
favorite Star Wars character yeah Zebula
[Laughter]
and for this to be anime he also plays
the Cowboy Bebop himself yeah it's not
Shrek uh spikes
you're right man it was defeated I'd
never get that right that is crazy and
I've I've restored a lot of faith and
confidence in myself ever said since I
missed a med best he should have wrapped
his way and you gotta motivated the
people honestly wait for it have you
seen blind spotting
no the the he wrote them co-wrote that
movie yeah he's amazing in it have you
seen a the new uh We're not gonna do
this we're gonna be here forever
but yeah I know this this was great at
the end of the day like the message of
Hope in the people is is also a nice
thought yeah now I'm thinking about this
had Hamilton written yes I'm too cynical
yeah
if I would have shot them down yeah
right oh I just throw them out of
cocktail yeah I call it a day it was
heartbreaking when the guy is sacked I
mean he died for a good cause though
they also like imagine waking up to
being like like pool party thrown into
the uh what an awful way to go and
that's like a long drop what do you
think he thought about
um no I should have not done this
should have not followed the light
all right last last one right let's do
it wow man this season flew by
yes
Nate episodes
instances give me Lord more and more and
more
okay
good for the korbas so interested to see
this animation Style
it could be funny
that's gonna be funny I don't think so I
think it'll be cute
wow look at that shot wow the dimensions
can you smell it Greg
don't jump
it's her song is this the plot of Frozen
two
[Music]
oh this feels meditative
she must be checking in with Port
security she'll be here soon
interlock
have that same kettle
sounds yummy remember to keep your
distance out
Jedi perhaps it's very unstable very
dangerous wow
[Music]
whoa what the hell
wild sometimes she has more curiosity
than since
oh
oh dumb little girls all over Vision
season two you've grown
and so curious
I love her fashion
hmm
I have some business in town but perhaps
I'll visit the mine later and see the
new deposit
cannot keep happening to use your voice
near the crystal is dangerous wow
frightens me to think what will happen
when I'm not there to protect you that's
what I say about John
I want you to be
to be totally a Jedi
don't do our happy town everything is
great and we never ever frown
[Music]
beautiful
hard to believe that Darkness was ever
here
look at that pseudo-mandalorian have a
good day at work out
I'll see you this evening remember don't
talk don't ever talk we're never gonna
fix that don't talk
that is that like a pimple what are we
oh
I want one
[Music]
bad feeling about
it so do I I got a bad feeling about
this
we've got a bath
[Music]
ah yes safety first child jeez
it's amazing that Civilization has made
it with the stupidity of children
oh yummy
wow this feels so tangible
this tunnel runs deep he's about to die
Big Time death because of the season
coming biggest he's gonna fall down an
even bigger hole Evil Dead
I really love how they capture the
essence of a crystal look at this camera
work
that's it
oh she's gonna slide I played enough
video games
oh she has to hold her mouth and nose
that she's going down what's wrong what
does she have a thing her natural
speaking voice is singing I know how to
put that together I don't think I've
been paying attention
oh you're so right
[Laughter]
we're gonna slide again
are you sure
all right
There You Go activate them all oh it's
not a curse
it's a thing of beauty she's gonna
transform them with her heart
[Music]
yeah some visual storytelling
our beautiful singing voice is gonna
restore the Purity to the crystals
[Music]
beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
fire
what uh what's going on
bad feeling confirmed
let's go dark
told you bigger hole oh
puppy oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hell yeah somebody's been playing
Jedi Survivor
[Music]
not dark enough it's okay Abby
that wasn't singing
you're right I didn't even think about
that
[Music]
she's like a siren
damn this is stunning
[Music]
Still A better ending than razza
Skywalker
speak now my child
she purified the Kaiba
how you had it all wrong you dumbass I
can help you nurture it but you would
have to come with me oh here we go
consider it
I'll be leaving in a fortnight
she was later slaughtered by Anakin
Skywalker when she was a young lady
I am she needs to be nurtured I feel
like she's pretty good on her own yeah
she just sang a mountain into peace I'm
proud
see Abby
oh
that is so touching
you're my favorite dumb little girl the
show has so far
[Music]
but why
finally something quiet she wasn't dumb
she was smarter than the dad
[Music]
the Empire's gonna attack now and that's
how they built Starkiller base
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh man that was lovely yeah it
was beautiful I mean I I
I wish they would have gone a little
deeper with it but what do you mean well
I feel like we in the very beginning we
had that that might even been the first
episode that beautiful piece that
used art as the painting episode yeah
it's communicate through the force and I
thought there was something really
interesting about the idea of
communicating with music
um but like that's the best she got I I
was expect like I don't know
like like lyrics I Wanna lyrics
I wanna I wanna hear your struggle and
song sister I don't know that was just
uh no it was fine I got some major
Frozen two vibes from it
can't ever be happy Star Wars fans dude
I literally understand nothing but
positive it was beautiful it was fun the
animation looked delicious I would have
even any one of those said pieces last
time I like felt that hungry watching
something was like during Willy Wonka
where I was like I want to take a bite
of that it's like a lollipop tree anyway
what'd you think Greg
um I thought it was really sweet I mean
it's one of those where it's it's got
this almost dreamlike tone to it so it
is about like
I I don't know I'm curious to know what
it's like for you guys when you binge
Visions because
you know on our end do you binge Visions
there are people who do the first time I
didn't have you I just talked to myself
it's awesome it's a great idea Michael
to talk to myself for a while and review
this by myself because it's different in
our in our setting you know where you
just like we got lights on and we talk
about it afterwards where you know as as
opposed to if you're just at home and
you binge it because to me this is the
kind of episode I'm like oh yeah I would
have loved this uh in a sense of just
like sitting back and like the the
visual illustrations when she does sing
and connect to the kyber crystals
um where it does feel like she's getting
in tune with like this isolation of just
her space and the Kyra crystals I think
is gorgeous so there was a lot of
there's a lot of beautiful stuff to it
and of all the ones that had the
claymation sense to it I thought this
was the best looking one
um yeah I mean I really feel like a
world brought to life yeah I I agree I
think uh they could have it could have
had some rap
uh
give me five minutes in a beat Greg uh
no I I think there was definitely
if I was alone watching this at my home
in the darkness well they don't ever
come here again Michael like then
recovery like I feel like my serotonin
post this episode would have been really
high but instead here I find myself with
glaring lights in your company yeah
feeling somehow more depressed than when
I started so
no this was I have to say season two
visions
um way better than season one way better
a lot I think they learned a lot of
lessons
um and I think part of that lesson being
uh I got this sense that there was a a
bit more
cohesion between the the Stu like Lucas
and and the animation companies whereas
I think last time they just like come up
with anything I think this time there
might have been like some direction I'm
super I would I would have liked a
little bit more variety on C like a lot
of these if I just watch like one
so weak you know and then I I don't but
it does get to when you binge it and
you're like
God damn just a lot about like Ivory
crystals well it always leans back into
that like the very very spiritual
essence of Star Wars which I feel like
which is great for laconic storytelling
yeah yeah but that being said yeah I was
like that's a big SAT Word
uh but I I feel like for this sort of
thing like I really enjoyed our episodes
where they're I mean there's only really
one right where there wasn't much use
the fort too I suppose uh and those were
the two of the strongest episodes the
French Resistance piece and the
Bane's origin story of the dark hole
from what she came from yeah I mean but
I I still I really there wasn't as
opposed to Vision season one I was like
I'm not gonna remember the I don't
know but but there were some standout
ones and vision season one the one that
were David Harbor did the voice with the
two Jedi and the crazy old guy I loved
the the very first one they did that was
like uh black and white um that was
excellent
um but here the the variety palette was
a big Saving Grace and and you do get
the sense of unique voice for each one
even right down to this one
um but yeah I do think there should be
some coordination at least with
hey you know we got a lot about like
light versus dark and uh it was just
like I know it's like traditional Star
Wars but it's like a bite-sized mediums
when you're starting a new story it's
like this
I think that's an interesting note for
The Animation Studios yeah because I'm
sure there is a
degree of freedom in the creative about
some kind of pitching process probably
just got like a time limit
yeah I know that's exactly what it time
and budget limit yeah uh but
I think there is or probably just budget
honestly like you can make it as long as
you can go because the lanes did really
vary from piece to piece
um they were mainly 15 minutes on
average but there was a few that were a
little bit longer there was one that was
like eight and nineteen that's one the
one the one in Japanese
nine there was one that was long
that one in particular did not as much
for me as I wanted it to but uh it
started off like a wood but then it
didn't yeah then it landed pretty flat
but all in all uh this was just a a
wonderful exercise and creative
storytelling I mean I feel like uh and
for those that are like aren't in the
film world uh
this kind of felt like going to a film
festival
uh only they were good
yeah I've been to some shitty film I'm
telling you guys just spill festivals
sound way more excited yeah as a winner
of many I can confirm it's a it's not
necessarily the greatest barometer of
it's like wow if we won that's bad news
uh but uh no but it it had that kind of
what I imagine some of the more premium
film festivals feel like yeah
um you know but all in all I think uh uh
I love the timing of this because there
is a slight pause in Star Wars content
until the end of summer and I feel like
this is a nice kind of hold this over
well
you know while we wait because I want to
see one episode that really I want to
see something that really does explore
the debate of when they asked because it
happened like several times in the
season of the child has to come with me
and then like the fade two this child's
coming I want one where it's just
that just the contemplation just the
debate of like like it starts off there
and like really explain the odd like
like a play like I I feel like you could
achieve that and we might see something
like that in Tales of the Jedi which I
feel like is a really are they coming
back yeah they got confirmed for season
two oh those are great yeah no it was it
was really strong
um and I like that like consequential
wise like it's just like ah Dave filoni
wanted to tell this story and we have
all the character models yeah true so
um well reject Nation I would love to
know your thoughts Greg is indifferent
to your personal opinion care less what
you think about anything guys but me on
the other hand I religiously read the
comments and I always love uh reading
what people have to say especially about
me oh sweet well the day you guys turn
on me I turned that hurt into anger
which is how you should handle your hurt
man all the men out there in
relationships well and you're hurt lash
out with rage
well you heard it here first folks uh
rage follow the darkness best way to do
it cool guys do it well uh we'll see you
during the show are we gonna tell them
about what we're gonna do together oh
yeah we want to do the holiday special
yeah because you never finished it I
can't I've I said I can't but we're
gonna have to it's it's that'll be my
first movie review with you I've never
oh yeah it would be it's two hours it's
a feature I know that was the part that
turned me off as I'm like whatever
little Clips I've seen of holiday
special I've been like I don't think I
ever want to watch this I feel like by
the time it's done I'll have pulled all
of my teeth out like I think we should
take something
that's a hot take and um like G fuel
did I do it right
probably not all right reject Nation May
the force be with you and until the
holiday special
good luck
laughs
[Music]